hey youtubers happy memorial day since
there was no new episode of Game of
Thrones this week I wanted to do a
special bonus video this is going to be
all about Dorne and the Martel's we've
gotten a bunch of new information about
filming locations as well as new
characters that they're casting so this
is going to be a short history on Dorne
as well as a breakdown of some of those
new characters so we only know about the
new characters we haven't learned about
any actual actors being cast yet quick
heads up I'm doing my weekly giveaway
with this video just because there
wasn't any episode video typically I do
a weekly giveaway that's just type 2
episode reviews but since it's just a
bonus video this week all you have to do
to participate is be a subscriber and
leave a comment on this video it's just
my way of saying thank you to all you
guys for being so awesome it's a
twenty-dollar amazon gift card so i'll
announce who the winner is whenever I
post my next game of Thrones bonus video
this coming Sunday a lot of you've also
been asking me about Oberyn Martell vs
the mountain and their fight that
they've been teasing since episode 7 i'm
actually going to wait to talk about
that till the episode airs just to avoid
spoilers also even though I'm going to
be talking about Dorne and some of the
new characters none of it is going to be
spoilery stuff but I will just mention
again as I start talking about the
characters to be careful in case you
don't want to know anything about season
5 let's start with torn though for
anyone who's like WTF Doran Martel's and
you're just unsure about who all these
characters are most of what we know
about Dorne from the show is that house
Martell rules there and they still have
a Prince Oberyn Martell older brother
Doran I've already kind of explained why
Dorne gets a prince and the other seven
kingdoms only have lords but basically
it's because they resisted Aegon's
conquest they're just extra badass in
the first couple of episodes Oberyn also
kind of let little things slip about
dorrance culture most notably that women
are not subservient to men in the way
they are and a lot of the other seven
kingdoms for instance if Brienne lived
there she could have been a night no
problem there wouldn't have been any
gender inequality and Cersei had she
been born there would have also gotten
the same status as a male heir Oberyn
himself is you know something of a
sexual omnivore just humping his way
across the world but in general the
culture is just much more openly
promiscuous so for example Cersei would
be called a [ __ ] in King's Landing for
sleeping with a bunch of men but where
she endured there would not be as much
of a stigma so now let's talk a little
bit
the formation adorned kind of leading up
to present day the first men actually
settled Westeros by crossing a land
bridge that extended from the Eastern
continent to Dorne but during their war
with the children of the forest it said
that the children broke the land bridge
to keep more people from coming over
Dorrance culture are at least as little
as we've seen of it from Prince Oberyn
is mostly influenced by roy near they
were actually a people that were
conquered by the Valyrian freehold and
then fled to the Seven Kingdoms that was
about a thousand years before the events
on the show right now their leader
Nymeria who's also the same name as
Arya's direwolf led about 10,000 men to
Dorne and formed an alliance with the
Martel's that were living there and then
they went on to conquer the area that
eventually became Dorne as we know it
right now so over time a lot of that
Eastern influence sank into their
culture the current falling out between
Dorne are the Martel's and the crown is
mostly about the Lannisters specifically
Tywin Lannister over the death of
Princess Elia she was Prince Doran and
over and sister who was married to
Rhaegar Targaryen that's the person that
Oberyn was talking about the mountain
murdering during Robert's rebellion in
the sack of King's Landing whatever he
was talking to Tyrion in the black cells
supposedly the mountain was only doing
all those horrible things on the orders
of Tywin Lannister because he is a
Lannister Bannerman Prince Durant also
kind of suspects the same thing as
Oberyn so he's allowing Oberyn to learn
more about what happened although the
murdering spree that Oberon teased in
the black cells is just him going above
and beyond the call of duty in the name
of revenge and that's basically where
we're going to pick up with episode 8
it's going to be him kind of taking one
step forward down that path so moving on
to season 5 news just talking about
filming locations first the crew was
spotted looking for places to film in
Spain which the terrain kind of doubles
for Dorne so there's also a lot of
casting news that supports the idea that
Spain is going to be Dorne in season 5
there have been about 12 new casting
call announcements for characters from
the books most of them are Martell
characters from Dorne and the rest are
just scattered through various regions
so I'm going to start with the Martell
characters first and just work my way
down first up is Prince Doran Martell
he's only been mentioned on the show but
he's the ruler in Dorne Oberon's older
brother he has gout which actually makes
it really hard for him to walk which is
why he sent over
to King's Landing in that first episode
on the show Oberyn just said he was ill
and sent his regrets the character is
about in his 50s he's very smart very
powerful I don't necessarily think of
him as being like Tywin Lannister he's
much younger and he's very wise but he's
not evil he's just very very calculating
then there's Tristan Martel that's
Prince Duran's youngest son and his air
whenever Tyrion arranged for marcela to
go to Dorne in season two he also
arranged for her and Tristan to become
betrothed moving on with more Martell
children we have the sand snakes I know
everyone's going to get really excited
about this in case you don't know
there's eight of them total the show is
only casting a couple of them but
they're all Oberyn Martell s bastard
daughters he actually mentioned them to
Cersei whenever they were walking in the
garden during episode 6 they were all
born to women in varying degrees of
social stratum including septa's common
women and highborn women but the one
thing that they do all share in common
is that they have Oberon's eyes and
they're all very very deadly they're
nicknamed the sand snakes is just a riff
on Oberon's nicknamed the red Viper the
ones the show is casting include Obara
who always kind of thought of as the
official leader their group she's the
oldest daughter and she was kind of
raised in a very militaristic style as a
fighter so I think of her as like a
Brienne type person who just incredibly
badass with a very very hot temper they
cast to other sand snakes in its Nymeria
and tying they're not quite as badass as
Obara but they're very very deadly then
there's areo Hotah he's basically like
Barristan Selmy to Prince Doran he's
like his personal bodyguard who's just
been with him for a long long time so
the other season five characters aren't
Martell or Doran characters so I'm just
gonna list them off in no particular
order there's septa anela she's part of
a special group of religious leaders in
King's Landing that rule on matters of
faith then there's the High Septon who's
the head of the faith of the seven in
King's Landing he's like the Pope in
King's Landing basically then there's
Lolly's Stokeworth who everyone will
remember Braun talking about having just
wed in the last episode she was also a
book character that had a bunch of
moments they just cut out of the show
they just didn't show them then there's
a really interesting character from
Circe's past called Maggy the Frog she's
a fortune-teller whenever Circe was a
little girl she went to her for a
reading she basically gave her this
really horrific prophecy of
her future the character is supposed to
make a brief appearance so maybe there
will be a flashback because supposedly
she was pretty old whenever so she went
to see her as a child then the last two
characters are you zan who's a slaver
and marine and the wave whose another
character who I'm not going to talk
about just because it's a little bit
spoilery because some of you may have
read the books and probably know a lot
about each of these characters please
use spoiler tags if you want to
speculate about them in the comments
just because a lot of people have not
read the books so because next week's
episode is called the mountain and the
Viper I might do another dorm bonus
video but regardless I will do another
bonus video and another round of the
giveaway so be sure to subscribe to get
everything feel free to leave me
suggestions for that bonus video if you
want me to do something totally
different right now click here to catch
up on episode 7 and click here to learn
all about the wildlings thank you so
much for watching I'll see you guys
tomorrow high fives
you